[Music]
hi my name is elizabeth deprenzio of
earthen element and i'm a los
angeles-based ceramicist
earthen element is a ceramic studio and
we're inspired by nature and we try and
bring those elements into your home
we create colorful functional day-to-day
use
tableware it's a really beautiful
relationship
between food and plating you have your
plate that
you've made with your bare hands and
you've created this beautiful meal with
your hands and you combine the two
and it just makes the experience so much
more beautiful and organic
the way we make our plates is we roll
out a large
piece of slab
we then take our plate template and
we cut out our plates we then take the
clay
and we throw it down on our plate mold
from there we bring down our [ __ ] arm
and the [ __ ] arm has a profile tool
connected to it
so once you pull it down it actually
starts molding and shaping the plate
from there we adjust the plate a little
bit we put it on the sun to dry for 30
minutes
so first when i'm making a cup is i
measure out
my clay and usually with my cups i
measure out
about a pound from there i throw the
clay
on the wheel i wet my hands i wet the
piece and i just get to work
the first thing you want to do is cone
your piece up so when you're conning it
looks like a little cone
and we're doing that just to get all
those weird little air bubbles out
so once you do that a few times you then
bring the cone down into
this little birthday cake is what we
like to call it
take your two thumbs insert into the
middle of the piece
and you're going to start pulling the
walls out and creating your bottom of
the cup
from there you're going to start pulling
the walls up and this is what gives the
cup its height
[Music]
i then cut out all my little moons and i
attached those moons one by one by hand
what we use is we call it slip and it's
basically
it's like the potter's glow
what's so important about a mug is
start to get attached to their mugs and
it becomes their everyday mug and it
becomes their morning ritual and it's
how they start their day
with a bowl you really want to make sure
that the shape
is something that's easy for someone to
hold and
easy to eat out of
i really try and make sure that the bowl
is really round and then it feels good
in my hands
trimming is basically cleaning the edges
and the rim of either a bowl or a plate
just so that
it's smooth and it doesn't scratch
[Music]
once bone dry it gets fired for the
first time
when we fire that's at around 1800
degrees
and it becomes what we call bis squares
bisquare is fired pottery that
is ready for glazing once the bisque
wear
comes out of the fire we sand the piece
we put it back on the wheel and we wax
parts of the plates
and parts of the pieces that we don't
want glaze to touch so that would be the
bottom of cups
the rim of a plate and the rims of bowls
after the pieces are waxed we then mix
our glaze
and we have all of our colors in each of
their own glaze bucket
and we mix each one just to make sure
all those elements and compounds are
mixed well together
and then it gives one beautiful coat to
a piece
a lot of our plates and our cups have
this striped design
so we keep that design going and we dip
half the plate we let that dry then we
dip the other side
and it creates like this stripe in the
middle of all of our plates and bowls
what's so special about a plate is it's
almost
the canvas for a painter especially when
we're dealing
and working with chefs and designing for
their restaurant and what they're
cooking
they're playing with colors they're
playing with textures so for them it's
also really important to
have something that's just as beautiful
and looks well
with what they're making and what
they're cooking
once we have everything glazed it enters
the kiln
and we fire at 2200 degrees
it'll fire for about 12 hours overnight
and then the next day we let it sit for
about five hours to cool down
once it reaches around 2-300 degrees we
start like peeking and taking pieces out
the clay is called speckled buff clay
and
those pop up during the glaze firing you
can't see them during greenware
or even bisquer you see the final
product once it comes out of the glaze
after we take those fired pieces out we
have to sand
every single piece make sure the bottom
is smooth that way it doesn't scratch
the surface of somebody's table
from there we pack it and we ship it out
to our customers
what makes us unique from other pottery
studios is our colors
we're not afraid to color outside the
lines and redefine
what tableware should look like some
people have a relationship with their
food
they have a relationship with their
favorite sweater and i think there are a
lot of foodies and chefs and people like
me that have a relationship with their
tableware and their favorite cup
a cup a bowl of plate to me is something
that you use every single day what we
drink and eat from is really important
it's how we start our day
it becomes part of your day to day
ritual and so i think it's really
important to love what you eat off of
that's the best part of this whole thing
is bringing joy to other people
you